thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air which now comes
with nebula for free link in the
description
the supreme court's decisions on
president trump's tax returns are in
now remember there is no legal
requirement that presidential candidates
or
presidents for that matter released
their tax returns from any particular
year
but despite the lack of legal
requirement for the last 30 years almost
all presidential and vice presidential
candidates have released
years of their personal tax returns
during that time every person nominated
for the president as a democrat or
republican has released their tax
information
except for president donald trump the
self-proclaimed billionaire whose
companies filed for bankruptcy six times
has been extremely guarded about
releasing any information about his
financial status
well he said he would release them i
will release
my tax returns against my lawyer's
wishes
i will absolutely give my return but
then decided not to well i'm not
releasing tax returns because as you
know they're under audit
the financial information supposedly
revealed that president trump was
deeply in debt for much of the 1980s and
1990s
and that he borrowed lots of money from
overseas entities and that in multiple
years he claimed more financial losses
than all but two other u.s taxpayers
some people reacted to this news with
the phrase so what you know the only one
that cares about my tax returns are the
reporters okay they're the only ones
while others believe that the
revelations were just the tip of the
iceberg
but in 2018 the new york times said that
they obtained years of financial data
about president trump and his various
organizations
from anonymous sources which we now know
include the president's niece
mary trump who is writing her own
biography of the president but the state
of new york subpoenaed president trump's
financial records in connection with
potentially
the campaign finance violations that
michael cohen the president's lawyer has
already gone to jail over
meanwhile in congress three oversight
committees of the house of
representatives has subpoenaed president
trump's accounting firm and multiple
banks
looking for information about the
president's financial history
president trump challenged all of these
subpoenas and the cases wound up
in the supreme court although the cases
obviously include president trump
directly the stakes go far beyond that
in the upcoming presidential election
these decisions will determine just how
much power the president
any president not just the sitting
president has to control the legal
process
against the presidency in the future and
these cases are a mixed bag
everyone wins and everyone loses
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because it looks like some of
the president's information is going to
be disclosed to district attorneys and
potentially the public
the supreme court has just decided two
major cases regarding the accessibility
of a sitting president's tax information
and financial records
what did they decide and what does this
mean for president trump and his
upcoming bid for re-election
well let's dive in and get down to brass
tax this is
a tale of two cases the very long
2020 supreme court term has finally come
to a close with the court finally
resolving
the two cases involving donald trump's
tax and financial information
so how did we get here well the
president claims to be a self-made
billionaire my father
gave me a very small loan in 1975 and i
built it into a company that's worth
many many billions of dollars so
why is it so taxing for president trump
to show his taxes
well we don't know what if anything the
president is trying to hide in breaking
with precedent and refusing to disclose
his tax returns
but that picture might have been made
clear when the new york times published
a pulitzer prize-winning article
entitled
trump engaged in suspect tax schemes as
he reaped riches from his father
the article was a deep dive into the
finances of donald trump and his father
fred trump senior
as well as the rest of his immediate
family the article made two major
findings first
president trump got a whole lot more
than a one million dollar loan from his
father fred trump as the president had
always claimed
secondly president trump along with his
siblings engaged in a variety of tax
schemes
that many tax experts said were illegal
it's a fascinating read that definitely
deserves to be readdressed especially
since
we've sort of moved on from this
particular scandal but some of the
highlights
include that not only did president
trump dissemble
when he claimed that he only received a
1 million loan from his father to start
his own business
which he allegedly paid back with
interest the new york times discovered
that actually president trump's
father loaned him north of 60 million
dollars at the time or
140 million dollars in today's money and
that he received at least
413 million dollars in today's money
from his father's estate
much of which might have been received
by dubious and potentially illegal tax
schemes
he engaged in along with his siblings
and these schemes
included potentially creating sham
corporations to disguise gifts from
president trump's parents to himself and
his his siblings
to just undervaluing several real estate
holdings in their parents estate to
avoid paying more taxes on those
particular holdings
and some in the trump family have
already faced consequences from the new
york times article
for example president trump's sister
marianne trump berry once a federal
judge was forced to retire
after the article disclosed that she and
her siblings were co-owners of a shell
company that
allegedly siphoned cash from their
father's business by just
making up purchases in addition the
inflated receipts were allegedly used to
justify rent increases for thousands of
tenants
barry quit in order to stop a judicial
ethics investigation into her conduct
though
she did get to keep her 200 000 pension
on the other hand the president has
managed to escape
scrutiny of his own taxes largely by
stonewalling
the house and district attorneys who are
asking for
that financial information and as a
result at this time the public
can't be certain that the president is
either guilty or innocent
of these allegations which takes us to
the two supreme court cases that were
just decided
the first is captioned as trump versus
vance vance in this case being the
famous
someone say infamous new york district
attorney saivans
now i know it seems like ancient history
but you might recall that the
president's old lawyer michael cohen
went to prison for tax evasion and
violating campaign finance law
his crimes were paying an adult film
star stormy daniels and former playboy
model karen mcdougall
to stay quiet about their alleged sexual
encounters with president trump
now there's no way to know for sure but
it's possible
that president trump was the unindicted
co-conspirator
individual one who engaged in a
conspiracy with michael cohen
of course the name has been redacted so
it's impossible to know for certain that
president trump was in fact individual
number one
but notwithstanding the district
attorney for new york cyrus vance
subpoenaed trump's accounting firm
mazers usa
for eight years of business and personal
tax records in connection with
president trump and the trump
organization's potential role in the
hush money payments made to mcdougal and
daniels before the 2016 election
this is a criminal investigation into
president trump's possible role in these
violations of law
since cohen claimed to be acting on
president trump's behalf
i am ashamed that i chose to take part
in concealing mr trump's illicit acts
rather than listening to my own
conscience the president filed for
emergency injunctive relief claiming
that as president the constitution
provides him with absolute immunity from
any criminal
process or investigation including
unofficial presidential conduct and the
associated subpoenas of third-party
records
this means that president trump thinks
he has a right to stop mazers and the
banks
vance also subpoenaed from complying
with a subpoenas and as a result of the
injunction
those financial records were never
turned over to the state of new york
so let's talk about president trump's
arguments here president trump argued
that
now is not the time to bring any
potential criminal charges against him
in the president's view there are only
two options for dealing with criminal
allegations against a current president
one congress can impeach the president
which we've crossed that bridge
or a state can launch a criminal
investigation after he or she ends their
term
as president the president contended
that defending a criminal inquiry would
interfere with his ability to discharge
his duties as president
and he asserted that criminal charges
are actually prohibited by the supremacy
clause of article 2 of the constitution
since state and local officials are
simply using their authority to quote
defeat
the legitimate operations of the federal
government the president argued that
it's not necessarily this one case that
would distract him from presidential
duties rather
it is quote the cumulative effect of
permitting every state and local
prosecutor to take the same steps the
district attorney did here
and while the president was making it
sound like there are thousands of local
prosecutors waiting to prosecute the
president
really he was arguing sort of the same
thing that bill clinton once did in
clinton versus jones that
any action taken against him would also
if so facto
be politically motivated and would swamp
uh the presidency in
responding to all of these different
inquiries some of which might be
legitimate but the vast majority of
which
might not be legitimate and might be
filed by democratic district attorneys
to stymie a republican president or
republican district attorneys to stymie
a democratic president
in response district attorney vance
simply said that there's no such thing
as unlimited presidential immunity from
criminal prosecution
vance argued persuasively that the
president's article ii immunity only
extends to official acts in his capacity
as
president and prior precedent involving
sitting presidents like clinton versus
jones and nixon vs fitzgerald
bolstered vance's arguments when paula
jones sued bill clinton for sexual
harassment that happened before he was
president
the court ruled that he was not entitled
to absolute immunity from civil
litigation arising out of events
which transpired prior to his taking
office and
that lawsuit was not dismissed and
clinton had to comply with the legal
process eventually he sat for a
deposition
which he famously perjured himself and
on the other hand the supreme court has
ruled in the past that president nixon
did have absolute immunity from damages
predicated on his official acts as
president
things that happened while he was the
president of the united states
but even in that case the supreme court
emphasized that a president is not
immune from criminal charges stemming
from his
official or unofficial acts while in
office and here
vance argued the same limitation on
presidential immunity also extends to
the supremacy clause which
supposedly prevented states from
interfering in the president's official
acts
vance argued that state criminal
investigations and subsequent subpoenas
are both
unrelated to the president's official
acts and would not interfere with
president trump's official duties as
president of the united states and
vance also pointed out that allowing a
president to have total immunity from
criminal or civil litigation
during the time the president is in
office could lead to total immunity
after one's presidential term has ended
as well as immunity from third parties
because if that immunity existed
it might impede the criminal
investigation because you might lose the
evidence or
the statute of limitations might run
because too much time has passed
so let's talk about how the supreme
court ruled in this particular case
here vance won and trump lost at least
on paper
the supreme court ruled seven justices
to two that in our judicial system
the public has a right to every man's
evidence in practice this means
the president does not have absolute
immunity from state criminal subpoenas
and state prosecutors do not need to
meet a higher standard to seek evidence
from
a sitting president although president
trump argued that criminal cases would
distract him from his job
justice roberts disagreed stating quote
two centuries of experience confirmed
that a properly tailored criminal
subpoena
will not normally hamper the performance
of the president's constitutional duties
and one of the things that led to people
thinking that this was a complete slam
dunk of a case
is that these subpoenas weren't directed
at the president himself but rather
third parties accountants and banks so
it's not like the president was going to
have to spend all of his time
responding to the subpoenas anyway these
records are held by third parties and
president trump cannot tell those third
parties that they can't respond
and although president trump argued that
criminal investigations would harm the
public perception of him
the majority opinion also dismissed this
claim by noting that the issuance of a
subpoena
would not have much of an effect on the
president's reputation
because when you get a subpoena you have
to provide the information there's no
necessary stigma related to that in
particular moreover grand jury
proceedings like what was going on in
new york are strictly confidential
which as the court pointed out should
prevent the very stigma that the
president anticipates
chief justice roberts who wrote the
opinion of the court also dismissed the
president's concern about thousands of
local prosecutors
trying to make a name for themselves by
investigating the president
the court pointed out that the legal
system already has safeguards to protect
against the
abuse of prosecutors that the president
envisions and while it's true that the
supremacy clause bars local officials
from interfering with the president's
duties
if a prosecutor is attempting to usurp
the president rather than simply
investigate a crime
then the president can challenge that in
court which is exactly what president
trump did in this case
and while the president and the
department of justice argued that state
prosecutors should be subject to a
higher standard in order to get evidence
from the president
the supreme court disagreed holding that
it would not be proper for
state criminal subpoenas to be subject
to a higher standard
and the broader point was that quote the
public interest in fair and effective
law enforcement cuts in favor of
comprehensive access to evidence
so if state grand juries had to meet a
higher standard it would quote
hobble the grand jury's ability to
acquire all information that might
possibly bear on its investigation
end quote the court also echoed vance's
concern that the evidence would be lost
if prosecutors had to wait until the end
of the president's term to see it
at the end in this first case trump
versus vance the court remanded the case
back to the lower court of appeals for
additional argument
in that argument president trump can
make new arguments about the subpoenas
and tried to prevent the subpoenas from
being enforced but he can't argue that
he is immune or that a higher standard
should apply
while there are still legal questions to
decide president trump is probably going
to lose most if not all of the battles
that he is going to have to fight in the
court of appeals
so while the biggest battle is over the
war
is not and president trump will probably
continue to make arguments that these
specific subpoenas
are overbroad or make other smaller
arguments about why they shouldn't be
enforced
so it's possible that this issue will
not be resolved before the 2020 election
though
since this was a grand jury proceeding
anyway it wasn't going to be open to the
public in any event
which takes us to the other tax case
that was decided at the same time trump
versus mazars
well trump versus vance was a defeat for
the president
trump versus mazars some argue that the
president prevailed at least because
he's going to delay the effect of the
decision at least for now
this case was kicked off when president
trump sought injunctive relief on four
subpoenas issued by three separate house
committees
the house financial services committee
the house intelligence committee
and the house oversight committee these
subpoenas were sent to trump's
accounting firm again
as well as two financial institutions he
used for personal and business reasons
the goal of these subpoenas according to
the house committees is to exercise
their basic roles of oversight in
legislative responsibilities now how
would this information
be used well the committee said it would
inform congress on subjects like whether
they need to impose new international
money laundering restrictions to
evaluate
current ethics laws for presidents or
determine if it should be mandatory to
have future presidents disclose their
tax returns
and obviously it goes without saying
that it might inform
past and future impeachment inquiries
now donald trump argued that
congressional committees are only
authorized to issue subpoenas for a true
legislative agenda
not for any law enforcement reason that
would be the purview of the executive
branch exclusively and president trump
also made the very broad claim of
executive privilege stating that
whatever powers congress holds it may
not deploy them in a way that keeps the
president from fulfilling the
obligations of his office
now the house of representatives argued
that this matter had already been
decided citing clinton versus jones in
which a sitting
president was not immune from civil
litigation the house committees argued
that quote article ii does not confer on
a president the power to resist
compulsory process directed at him
unless there is impairment of the
executive's ability to perform its
constitutionally mandated
functions the house committees argued
that this is clearly not the case in
this situation since
the subpoenas were not even directed to
the president so there's no actual
burden on the president himself
congress argued that it has the
legislative purpose for seeking
information if a subpoena seeks
information that will inform congress on
a subject that would likely lead to
legislation well detractors argued that
these assertions were so broad that it
would allow the house to seek personal
information from a president
about anything if it somehow could be
used to justify
a law the supreme court ruled seven to
two in a way that sort of splits things
down the middle
the court did reject president trump's
claim that he can raise executive
privilege over the information and did
acknowledge
that congress has the power to subpoena
information from the president so it can
craft legislation effectively
however the supreme court limited that
power and held that congressional
subpoenas are valid only if they serve a
valid legislative purpose and are not
intended to be
law enforcement efforts and the supreme
court for the first time articulated a
four-part test to determine if the
subpoenas
can be enforced against the executive
branch but just as it did
in the vance case the supreme court
rejected president trump's argument that
congress needs to
prove that the records are critical or
some incredibly high standard
applying such a high standard here
roberts explained again he wrote the
opinion for the supreme court
would risk seriously impeding congress
in carrying out its responsibilities
but the court also dismissed arguments
by the house that these subpoenas should
be treated like any other request for
documents
the court held that the house did not
take into account the quote
significant separation of powers issues
raised by congressional subpoenas
for the president's information and
articulated that when lower courts have
to decide whether to enforce a
congressional subpoena into records
involving the president
the courts should quote perform a
careful analysis that takes adequate
account of the separation of powers
principles at stake
among other things courts should
consider whether the president's papers
are really necessary
because the information cannot be
obtained elsewhere whether the subpoena
is
as limited in scope as it can be while
still serving congress's power
what evidence congress has offered to
establish that a subpoena advances a
valid legislative purpose
and what burdens a subpoena imposes on
the president and because the lower
courts did not adequately consider these
factors probably because these factors
didn't exist before the supreme court
case
the cases will now return to those
courts for additional proceedings
so there were two crucial questions
posed by the vance and mazar's cases
first can a state subpoena a current
president's personal records
as part of a criminal investigation and
the answer to that is
yes a state prosecutor has the right to
subpoena a sitting president or third
parties who hold
information about the current president
and those inquiries are not bound by any
kind of higher burden than
would normally happen under a state
investigation
and the second question was whether
congress can subpoena a president's
personal information
outside of a formal impeachment inquiry
and the answer is basically
yes but although congress may have the
right to subpoena personal information
about the president it'll need to show
that there is
really a legislative purpose for the
information and congress can't
necessarily do a phishing expedition
into the president's personal
information
in the end the court affirmed that the
president is not above the law
but the justices also kicked the can
down the road a little longer
pretty much guaranteeing that we won't
see the president's financial records
before the vote in november
now i have a lot more to say about the
political implications of these
decisions
and what it means in terms of the public
actually getting access to the tax
returns but that's probably not safe for
youtube which is why i put my extended
discussion
on nebula my creator friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiositystream
because nebula is a place where creators
can do what they do best
create it's a place where we can both
house our content ad-free
and also experiment with original
content new series that probably
wouldn't work
on youtube in fact if you liked this
episode the version that i put up on
nebula removes this ad entirely and
replaces it with that extended
discussion about
the president's tax returns and all of
the implications there
the bar has been set so low that
rejecting these incredibly stupid
arguments
is considered a win nebula features lots
of youtube's top educationalist
creators like thomas frank knowing
better polyphonic and lindsay ellis and
tons of others we also get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on youtube like
tom scott's amazing game show money
where he pits a bunch of famous
youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
work together or
profit individually it is amazing you
will love it so what does this have to
do with curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the internet
they love educational content and
educational creators and we worked at a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with the link in the description
not only will you get access to
curiosity stream but you'll also get a
nebulous subscription for free
and to be clear that nebula subscription
is not a trial it's free for as long as
you're a curiosity stream member
and for a limited time curiosity stream
is offering 26
off their annual plans that's less than
15
a year for both curiosity stream and
nebula less than 15
it's incredible and since you've got to
stay inside you might as well be soothed
by the voice of david attenborough
narrating tales about tiny hummingbirds
or join chris hadfield on a road trip
through the universe
or just watch tom scott torture your
favorite youtubers on nebula
so if you click on the link in the
description you'll get both curiosity
stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle
it's a great way to support this channel
and educational content directly
for just 14.79 per year that's
26 off so just click on the link in the
description or go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle clicking on that link really
helps out this channel so
what do you think about the court's
decisions and do you think that there
should be a federal law requiring
presidential candidates to reveal their
tax returns
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
talking about the protests and covid
related legal issues there's
a lot going on in the law so click on
this video and i'll see you
in court